declaration of result of for election of
a member of parliament for South
Pasadena and East arc on Thursday the
8th of June 2017 I para Mahendran being
the acting returning officer at the
above election do hereby give notice
that the number of words recorded for
each candidate at the send election is
as follows
Banerjee Pretender are not Liberal
Democrats 732 bog Paul British National
Party local people first 383 Harmon
Semyon Richard Philip the Green Party
680 metka Steven James the Conservative
Party candidate 26800 Taylor
Byron Kingsley Labour Party 15,000 and
321 visual Peter Robin the UK
Independence Party
you kept 3193 the total number of
electorate means 75 70 3537 ballot
papers issued 47,000 178 and they turn
out being sixty four point one five
percent and I do hereby declare that
Metcalf Steven James is duly elected as
Member of Parliament for the South
passage and and Easter party let's see
[Applause]
thank you very much indeed and just so
if you were to say thank you to the
returning officer to all his staff to
all the count staff to all those who
have run such a extraordinary and we'll
organized campaign and countless evening
thank you thank you to the police for
keeping us safe and for making sure that
the election was conducted in a proper
and safe manner thank you of course to
my team to my agent James one day I hope
to be able to join me in Parliament of
Aaron and support they all work
tirelessly we ran a a solid
old-fashioned campaign taking our
message door-to-door and through the
letter boxes talking to people and
finding out what their concerns were and
I will take that message back to
Westminster when I go back to work for
you on Monday
and of course the biggest thanks has to
go to the people of South basil Dhin
Andy's thorough they have put incredible
amount of trust in me again for a third
time and I will never forget it's them
that I serve and it is a true honor to
be the Member of Parliament for South
Basildon and Easter on the events of
this evening have yet to fully unfold
but whatever happens come the new
Parliament I will be there serving my
constituents standing up for them and
taking their message to the heart of
Westminster thank you for the trust
they've placed in me